everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today starts the 2015
US Chess Championship we have 12 of the
top Americans fighting for their shot at
the prize pool of $175,000 and also the
right to call themselves champion
today's match we're gonna be looking at
a game between two of the youngsters in
the field we have White's gonna be
played by Ray Robson 20 year old rating
of 27 70 actually won the junior
championship in 2009 so very very
talented young star for the United
States and this opponent playing the
black pieces today is Kate Roth 16 years
old he is the 2014 Junior Champion
so both of these guys are very young
both very experienced at winning
championships so we actually get to see
them faceoff in the first round and see
if any of them can make a big splash in
the US Championship we'll go ahead and
get started race starts with pani 4 upon
c5 9 f3 pawn to a d6 pawn to d4 and we
get into the neither earth defense after
Knight to f6 and then pawn to c3 pawn a6
this is the night off defense a lot of
different ways that white can respond to
this my personal favorite I like to play
Bishop here to c4 and then you're gonna
bring it back to Bishop here to b3 and
really just hone down on this long
diagonal right here since your
opponent's play pawn to d6 more than
likely they're gonna bring their pawn up
here to d5 they're gonna have a backward
pawn here on d6 that you can attack but
bring your Bishop back here to b3 is
gonna allow you just a lot of time to
attack this square here on f7 which is a
weakness for black early on this is how
Fischer like to play I studied a lot of
Fischer when I grew up so that I kind of
mirror his playstyle but Ray Robson
decided to play a little different he
played Bishop here to e3 and this is
more of the the modern mainline so you
see this more frequently and from here
we see play continued with pawn to e5 as
we talked about we do see a backwards
pawn here on d6 or something that white
can potentially attack later on down the
road Knight back here to b3 Bishop here
to e7 and black kinda has two options
you know Kaden can either play Bishop
here to e7
he could play queen here to c7 this is
kind of a semi-open file for his queen
to attack so he does have options
decides to go ahead and opt for the
bishop here to e7 with a quick castle on
the King side we see pawn here to f3
just supporting this pawn structure
right here since white no longer has his
queen pawn then he's gonna be looking to
just play pawn to f3 solidify his pawn
structure and then castle on the Queen
side which is always exciting because
after black plays Bishop here to e6 then
we do see Queen to d2 and then castling
on both sides of the board which usually
just means fireworks and that's exactly
what we're gonna see in this game as
well so as we look at both sides White's
really gonna be looking to dominate the
Kings side Rea really has a strong Queen
side defense he'll eventually want to
make sure that he gets his King here to
be one to protect the square here on a
two but it's gonna be very easy for him
to just push all his material up on the
King side also wants to make sure that
he continues to control the square here
on d5 this is a very central square that
right now I doesn't have a pond so he
needs to make sure that his other pieces
maintain that control later on he does
again have the ability to attack this
backward pawn here on these six now if
you're looking at Kaden side his option
is going to be just counter attack on
the Queen side he knows that his
opponent is just gonna be throwing the
kitchen sink at him on the Kings side
but the Queen side is again where his
opponent has castled and so he can start
to push a lot of opponent put a lot of
pressure on his opponent he does have a
nice little outpost here on d4 he can
get one of his pieces - he has a simio
pan foul here on the C file so he can
get both of his rooks involved really
attack white on the King side so from
here we see Knight here to d7 opening up
the door for the rook tin a8 to go ahead
and get involved into the game pawn to
g4 s we talked about why it's just gonna
throw pieces and material over onto the
King side pawn to b5 black
counter-attacking on the Queen side pawn
to g5 pawn to b4 and this was kind of
exciting when I saw this knowing that
both sides are kind of going right at
each other instead of just moving this
night right here deciding you know what
let's go ahead and change it up let's
just go ahead and trade off Knights and
just
a pretty aggressive game so we do see an
exchange off the board after the Queen
takes and the knight recaptures the
night up here to a5 getting ready to
attack here on c6 if he needs to now
would be a mistake you know but the
bishop could come here to a to raid is a
really good job of setting a lot of
traps that may not look like traps but
if the bishop were to come down here to
a2 we get to Knights who see six
attacking the Queen if the Queen moves
then the knight takes here on e7 check
forcing to take the knight here and then
all of a sudden pawn to b3 this Bishop
is now trapped the Queen can come here
to be two and this bishops going to fall
so that's not going to be good
Kaden does not fall for the trap instead
after the knight comes here to a5
decides to go ahead and play rook over
here to c8 which I really love again
getting your pieces active on the board
Kaden really needs to make sure that
he's attacking this Queen side with his
powerful pieces like his rooks so after
the rook here to c8 we do see a knight
here to c6 attacking the Queen after the
Queen here it comes here to e8 decides
to go ahead and take AB AB Bishop off
the board this is gonna be somewhat of
an open game so anytime you can take
your opponent's and bishops off the
board especially if you can trade with a
knight that's definitely not a bad thing
so after the Queen recaptures then
cleaning up here to a5 this is now a
very important square in peace the pawn
here on a6 we see the Queen here on a
five in both the bishop here on f1 are
attacking this square so black has to be
very aware of this isolated pawn on here
in a6 or it's going to vol fall very
quickly after the rook here to a c6 we
do see white plague King over here to be
won it would be a mistake if we saw
Bishop here to a 6 because rook to a 8
would be completely devastating so Rey
recognizes that decides to not take with
his Bishop that would be a very
detrimental plays King over here to b1
as we talked about definitely a safe
move he needs to make sure that he does
have a piece defending this square the
bishop here on e6 all of a sudden kind
of disappear on you but it's definitely
attacking the square at a2 so needs to
make sure that he can roam around with
this Queen and still have control with
his cane here on b1
protecting the square on a to Cayden now
plays pawn here to d5 I personally am
NOT a huge fan of pawn to d5 I think if
we look at what he's trying to do rook
to c8 makes a whole lot of sense he gets
his other rook involved into the action
it doubles up as rooks on this semi-open
c-file White's gonna have to be more
reactive in this spot can't really do
anything except try to defend against
this attack but pawn to d5 all of a
sudden allows Rey Robson to really have
an exchange that I think favors him so
after the pawn takes we do see the
knight take here on d5 the rook taking
up here after the bishop takes the Queen
takes and white is kind of up as far as
the material definitely has the double
Bishop pair which is going to be just a
pain for black to have to deal with and
so we basically have two bishops for a
rook and I would much rather have the
two bishops on board the new Brooke
especially going into a very very open
in game White's gonna be able to control
a lot of the board with his bishop so I
don't really I don't really think that
Caden made the best play with pawn here
to d5 but you know you have to live with
it and then hopefully he can find a way
to get out of this mess in the endgame
rook here to d6 forcing the Queen to
come back here to e4 a now comes down
here to d1 forcing the bishop to come
back here to c1 always good to make your
opponent play defense it doesn't want to
make sure that he loses to a checkmate
Queen here to a g5 and then pawn up here
to f4 very important how black captures
he does correctly capture with his Queen
if you were to recapture with his pawn
on f4 then all of a sudden white can
play Bishop here to d3 threatening mate
here on h7 black would have to respond
you know pawn here to g6 would be an
option
getting the Queen involved and then all
of a sudden you would see this rook here
on d1 fall so that would definitely be
bad and said black correctly takes with
his Queen here on f4 and Rey decides to
go ahead and just exchange off the board
he sees that he does have the material
advantage he can dominate the end game
with his Bishop pair and
getting the Queens off the board is
exactly what he's looking to do now
Bishop appear to g2 seeing if black
wants to exchange more material off the
board and it looks like Kaden does so we
do see an exchange off so now we really
come down to the end of the game with
two bishops versa the rook and the extra
pawn here which i think is usually going
to favor the double bishops pawn here to
g5 pawn up here to see for rook over
here to see H trying to protect this
pawn pushing any further on the c5
Bishop up here to d5 nice little outpost
for why it's going to be very difficult
for black to really do much with this
bishop in this pawn here on c4 and then
both sides are going to get their kings
involved again any time to get into the
endgame or even to the late stages of
the mid game once the Queens are off the
board it's usually pretty safe to go
ahead and get your Kings involved they
can be a very very powerful piece in any
attack King up here to see - King to f6
pawn to b4 and Rey pretty much has
decided that hey his win condition is to
go ahead and push he has them pawn
majority on the Queen side and on the
other side Kaden is really looking to
push with his pawn majority on the King
side so King here to f5
punt up here to a4 pawn to d4 pawn b5
after the exchange right here let me see
the rook over here to b8 Bishop e2 a 3
and then pawn to f3 and this one subtle
move is probably the the biggest mistake
in the game for Kaden and afterwards he
would kind of look at this move but if
you look at what White's trying to do he
wants to push this pawn forward here on
the B file and after pawn to f3 then all
of a sudden Bishop to c5 is devastating
it allows the pawn - now push forward
here to b6 it can now come to b7 it's
protected by the bishop and then all of
a sudden you can see the bishop come
here to a7 the rook can no longer
support this square and blacks just
going to crumble right away now if
instead black does not play pawn here to
F the
let's say he plays King to e5 then if we
were to see Bishop here to see five to
try to stop the attack then black can
just go ahead and take here on b5 after
that the pawn takes here on b5 we could
see the King take here on d5 he could
now threaten to you know take this
Bishop and then he could take this pawn
chase it up the board why it's not gonna
be able to promote this pawn it's gonna
be very difficult for white to ever end
up with the material to win the game and
then all of a sudden Black has a huge
pawn majority on the King side it's not
clear how he would actually turn this
into a victory but definitely a much
better situation than having his pawn
here on f3 and then playing a bishop
here to c5 and having no way to really
push forward or now stop this pawn
pushing up the board so we're over here
to e8 pawn to b6 as we talked about push
your past pawn that's number one rule in
chess pawn here to h5 just trying to
counter-attack on the Kings side but
it's just not really gonna do too much
pawn here to b7 getting ready to promote
to a queen here on the b8 Square pawns
to h4 Bishop here 287 just another layer
of protection once this pawn pushes
forward pawn to h3 King over here to d2
wants to make sure nothing crazy happens
if this rook does pass the Kasim here on
the e-file that the King can just come
over here and make sure that you know
rate blocks any try that black has to
promote a pawn right here upon here to
g3 and then the Queen up here to b8 and
this is where the game in Akina decided
to go ahead and resign there's just no
way for black to stop what White's doing
right here so really awesome game to see
some of the youngsters from the United
States square off Robson again just been
dominating for a long time at 20 years
old definitely one of the young stars so
excited to see him in round 1 get a huge
victory Kaden only 16 bright future
again the junior champion played
extremely well a few moves that could
have been a little bit better but
excited to see him actually in the
tournament always good to see
young Americans doing well in chess so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
the u.s. Chess Championship is one of my
favorites I get to see a lot of players
that I follow throughout the year but
usually not at this high of a tournament
level so it's it's exciting for me to
cover so I'll be trying to do as many
matches as I can so stay tuned and
thanks for watching